hey guys how's it going so i'm super
excited to make this video for you today
this video is going to teach you a few
things number one how i shoot my youtube
videos number two how i shoot my gaming
videos if any of you guys watch my vlogs
you know that i've been working really
hard reorganizing and putting together
ikea furniture and trying to put it all
together and become a little more
organized everything that i talk about
today i will put in a link below
there'll be a collection that'll take
you to more collections of either things
that i think are cool things that i want
i also have a camo collection make sure
you guys check that out at the end of
this video or check it out now while
you're watching the video at the same
time put it in another tab do whatever
it is that you do so to start this video
off i'm going to start and show you how
i would make a basic youtube video now
there's a bunch of different things you
can use the easiest way to make a video
for youtube is to use either an imac or
one of the macbooks they have an
eyesight built in comes with imovie
basically you just turn on the camera
start talking and edit in imovie when it
comes to audio i'm super picky i always
use either a blue microphone or a yeti
microphone which just plugs directly
into your computer using usb as far as
lighting i like to shoot during the day
and have daylight just wafting in
honestly for the longest time before i
actually got led lights i still to this
day almost prefer using these simple
stand lights for actual videos like this
i just recently upgraded to a canon 70d
and i by far would recommend this above
all other slrs because it does autofocus
but you can use many different
microphones right now i'm using a
sennheiser wireless microphone so i've
got a microphone
right here if i'm shooting with more
than one person i will use the rode
video mic it's also great because i
travel a lot so i like to be able to
have things that are smaller and compact
that i can just take with me on the go
now speaking of on the go my iphone is
probably my number one go-to camera when
it comes to vlogging it's easy i always
have it with me and the audio is
actually really fantastic next up this
is my ultimate favorite vlogging camera
it's not the best quality because it is
a really old camera but it still is my
favorite and i've been using it for my
vlogmas videos it's the canon 960 now
this is probably maybe a four or five
year old camera but the audio on it is
perfect the video files aren't too huge
that if you're vlogging every day a lot
of the other ones massive files so i
still love this camera but if you are
looking to up your quality this is my
second go-to camera it's the canon n and
it's this cute little square camera it
has touch screen on the back it shoots
in 1080p and it also will connect to
wi-fi so you can take all of the photos
and the videos that you're shooting on
the go as long as you're on the same
wi-fi you can get them on your phone
immediately another vlogging camera that
i really really like is the samsung
galaxy camera the only problem is it's
kind of big but it's pretty sweet
because basically if you've ever used an
android phone this is essentially a
phone without the phone capabilities in
a camera body so now that you've got all
of these random things to make your
videos most of the time i use final cut
pro x now a lot of people always have
all these negative things to say about
it unless you've actually used it and
you get used to it for vlogging and
simple edits this is by far it's perfect
it may come as a surprise to many of you
but i've actually started using my pc
almost more than my mac which leads me
in to my gaming setup for my gaming
channel this is how i do it so for game
capture this is the little guy that does
pretty much all of the hard work this is
the elgato hd game capture so i have the
usb plugged into my pc and the hdmi in i
have plugged into my xbox now if you'll
notice i have three monitors this is
definitely not necessary at all but this
first monitor is what i have my gameplay
on the second two monitors are connected
to my pc from here i will connect this
headset into this astro mix amp and from
there i will connect the optical cable
from my xbox to the mix amp i will then
connect the mix amp to my computer so
not only will i be able to hear the game
audio i'll be able to use the built-in
microphone to record the voice over for
the gameplay after that i will switch
the logitech camera software to make
sure that it's using the correct mix amp
audio input so we'll not only be
recording the logitech video but it'll
be using the audio from the microphone
what mostly matters when it comes to a
lot of gameplay is the audio so i will
still use that yeti microphone or i will
use a headset that has built-in audio i
will then start the recording process
for the camera and the xbox in the
elgato game capture hd software kind of
at the same time so i play my game i
record the audio or record the video and
then i take this all into premiere and
from there i sync it all up edit it and
post it to the internet for all of you
guys to enjoy i still do all of this
editing myself and it takes a really
long time so when people are like why
didn't you post any gameplay videos it's
because i've either been spending all of
the time editing or i've just been
playing and not recording i'm moving on
to my gaming setup as you'll notice here
i have a bunch of hdmi cables that are
kind of coming up behind my little
entertainment center now what i'll do is
i will usually swap these out and put
them into the elgato game capture
depending upon which game system i want
to capture the monitors that i use are
asus monitors a lot of people are always
like how can you play games on such a
small screen i prefer playing on a
smaller screen there's so much less
screen lag when you're playing
first-person shooters i promise you try
playing on a massive 55-inch tv and then
drop down to one of these guys you'll be
like oh man mlg sign me up because i'm a
pro so this desk was my most recent
purchase from ikea i had a nice man come
and put it together for me i can hold
all of my games all of my consoles and
my cards against humanity this is the
best game in the world i don't know if
that means that i'm a terrible person
but if it does sign me up because this
game is amazing so i've got all these
files from shooting videos what do you
do with them all where do you store them
i'm a huge fan of these g drives purely
because they look good and they match
everything there may be better hard
drives out there i actually don't know
but i stand by these drives just
completely wholeheartedly i've never had
a problem with any of them so i've so
far
actually am pretty happy with them now
that i think about it they've survived
trips around the world thank you guys so
much for watching i'm super excited to
share with you guys some of my tips and
tricks on how i make youtube videos and
honestly the bottom line is if you have
a camera or an iphone or anything you're
set to go most of my first youtube
videos that i ever made were made on my
macbook with my eyesight you're on your
way to youtube victory
you